Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192. David P, this is a new favorite
caller of mine. This is one of the most confident
callers I've ever had. This caller says he is the
authority on UFOs and aliens and he is going
to now beyond any doubt. Tell us the truth,
the truth about UFOs. Listen to this.
Speaker 5: Yeah, David, great show. I
don't watch too often. I'm too busy. But I
have another follow up comment about UFOs.
Speaker 1: Loves the show, never watches
it. That's okay. I'll take the praise.
Speaker 5: You could bank on this. And I am
good when I do my research. I consider myself
the best. I We have a proven track record.
The evolution of our solar system before
the earth was formed and all the planet has yet
to repeat, has never been visited by probes or
observations from any repeat, any extraterrestrial
variety in the entire universe, or from
these baloney theories about multi
universes or fourth dimension or b never.
There had never been a UFO that landed
on this planet. No probes, no past spies,
nothing. There's no aliens living on this planet.
Speaker 1: Okay. All right. I think I think you
get it. I really a. Appreciate the caller
confidently putting that to rest. And I know
there are people in our audience with different
perspectives on this issue. But this if you go by
his confidence, he must be completely correct.
We have a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Sarah Huckabee Sanders says that if she is
governor, kids in the womb will be as safe as
kids in classrooms. Wait a second. That something
about that is not making sense. We will discuss
it. We have a study that finds that when a state
passes a concealed carry law, gun crime goes up by
33%. And we will also talk about the belief among
more than half of Americans that the Supreme Court
is coming for gay marriage sooner or
later after the Roe v Wade decision that
the Supreme Court is coming for
gay marriage. I happen to agree
and we will talk about that on today's bonus
show. Sign up at joint pacman dot com. You will
get instant access to the bonus show.
Speaker 2: That is a frickin.
Speaker 1: Predator, right? Not predatory at
all. If you like it, then you keep it. That's
how it is. Use the coupon code. Big voting 22.
To sign up at join pacman dot com. Get instant
access to the bonus show and then if all goes
well, I will be back here with you tomorrow.